[Music]
hello everyone
master dance porsche and this is games
of the week
and this time we are going to take a
look
at games the person who's best known as
polish fighter you might be asking who
is polish fighter well
it's the player formerly known as jan
kristov
so let's take a look at his games so the
very first game we're going to take a
look at
is duda versus avoid shack and
in this game two polish players are
going to go
at it which is very peculiar because
this was always the best to playing
so apart from the intrigue they're
playing
for honor as well so the game starts
with e4
e5 and
here you can see that
they're both playing it solidly they're
not
trying to take extra risks in fact
woetech is playing the solid lines that
his master slash
the champion he helped because he was
the second wishman
on second that is plays the most solid
setups
so knight f3 bishop b5 a6
now of course these days everybody and
their grandpa would go knight f6 playing
with the good old solid berlin but this
is
a specific enough matchup
between these two polish players a6
bishop a4 knight f6 castle
bishop e7 d3 now
voitacek is famously prepared no wonder
he is part of the team of vishwanathan
anand
so duda specifically does not want to
get into a deep
theoretical dispute now in case of
rookie 1
b5 bishop b3
castle you can end up in a heavy
theoretical duel
in the marshall variation which has been
played in
the famous world championship match
between kramnik and
lako and also has been sort of the big
topic
for the 90s and 2000s
so instead of going for
rook e1 duda decides to go for
a d3 over defending the
pawn and postponing this idea of moving
the rook to e1
in this way white is winning time but
also
eventually white will have to go c3 d4
and exert some pressure on the center
b5 bishop b3 d6 this is a typical slide
trick
by black although not an intentional one
like it's trying to consolidate the e5
pawn
but at the same time it's threatening to
go on knight
5. now some time ago
when grace shook and
karana tried for the world championship
title or to become a challenger
they came up with this idea of bishop d2
taking away that
a5 square and then
try to go on play a4
and continue that way but duda goes with
the traditional
c3 d3 creating a
little bit of a loft in case of knight
a5 there's always a bishop c2
and practice shows that the knight is
still
kind of misplaced over there on a5
and white wants to play d4 anyways and
this bishop will be there to support the
e pawn
so castles a4 undermining the b5 pawn
bishop d7 and
chess is getting more and more complex
as time goes on it's not because of the
computers
but humans are capable of
expecting future troubles so
here black's main plan is to go knight
a5
c5 which is actually called chigorian
style
named after the legendary russian player
so white decides to circumvent that now
you can circumvent that in both ways
you can go bishop a2 and if k in case of
knight a5 you can go b4
and just chase the knight away
or do what duda did and go bishop c2
with the same idea black
is just one tempo short if you go knight
t5 white will
go b4 and chase the knight away and then
time
the other idea is if you go knight a5
white will be able to go and strike in
the center
and black just does not have enough time
to reorganize
which for example would happen in case
of rook e1
c5 and the knight is back in time
to c6 guarding the e5 square
so rookie 8 rookie 1
h6 and here it's time for us
to find the classical spanish maneuver
there is this classical spanish maneuver
that is
very important to note because
that's the first thing you've got to
know if you want to play this open
so white is always trying to get that d4
move
in but d4 would never really work right
now
because of either e takes
c takes and bishop g4 or bishop g4
immediately putting pressure
on that knight pinning
the queen and there is threats of taking
and blowing up the center so white is
not quite
ready to make the push d3d4
therefore decides to embark on the
regular plan
of the spanish and that is to maneuver
this passive knight on b1
to a much better pasture of the g3
square
bishop f8 knight f1
d5 and black
is threatening to take on e4 now
for some players this wouldn't really be
a threat
they would just accept the fact that
white is not better here and just go
about an even position after knight g3
takes and takes but as
his online name shows young shisht of
duda is not known
for very tedious and pacifistic ways
he is there to have a fighting game so
he takes on d5
which is double-edged to say the least
why well white is giving up
a center pawn trades it off and now it
is black who has an extra pawn in the
middle
while white has none over there however
it is compensated by the fact that
black has a couple of weaknesses on the
queen side
and the target in the face of that e5
pawn
so there is ample compensation for duda
but there is a danger of black
overtaking
the advantage bishop d2
just developing and sort of putting a
waiting mode duda is waiting
for voitach's plans and it's actually
not that easy
to decide what black should do black can
keep the position as is go rook b8
and say if you trade that's fine with me
i've got a strong hold on e5 maybe a
weakness on b5 but how are you going to
get there
that would be a solid way of playing but
actually voitacek decides to
play b4 and be a bit more aggressive
sort of locking that bishop to that
passive d2 square
and here comes another nice little twist
by duda duda even though
is considered to be an aggressive player
he does have a good feel
for positional chests and his next move
is
going to be quite painful for wojteshek
so let's try to think about duda's next
move what could have
duda played here
so we already kind of see that this e
pawn is not really in danger just yet
it's well guarded by the knight and rook
although if you would try to overprotect
it with f6
then you would actually
open up the long diagonal for that
bishop
and that could lead to problems as
a couple of grandmasters would agree
now there is this classical weakness
in this type of position and that is the
a6
and now the xb5 pawn
and now that xb5 pawn moved to b4
it is actually lacking a bit of support
and do not make sure
that convoy never arrives so after e5
i mean a5 that a pawn is fixed and this
b4 pawn is somewhat isolated
from the rest of black's forces so b
takes b takes
knight f6 knight g3
rook b8 bishop a4
pressing on the v key pawn so yes
directly he's attacking the knight but
the real target here is the e5 phone
bishop d6 queen c2
knight a7 wouldn't be minding trades but
duda as we said is not that kind of guy
bishop b3 aiming for more bishop e6
now if this was a qualification event
you might be seeing this move
raise its ugly head and just
pester that rook with a very shocking
response of bishop d7
but as i said that's not going to happen
when
young shishtov duda is playing he will
try his utmost
to complicate matters so he instead
decides to take on e6
rook takes e6 and
trading mine itself isn't really making
a difference in this position
the big difference comes with the next
move by youngstov duda
if he can somewhat unbalance the
position he will get some good winning
chances
now it is not too hard
to find these moves if you recognize
that momentary disconnect between
black's pieces
that rook is sort of eyeing the
nothingness
on the b file there is actually nothing
happening over there
that knight on a7 is temporarily
moved away from the center of the action
so it is just high time for duda
to go d4 and with this knight far away
you can't really trade just yet
because that would allow rook takes e6 f
takes e6
c takes and then black would get a very
compromised structure
with this knight on a7
severely out of play let's mention queen
c4
and queen e6 is on the cards
so d4 knight c6
very good grand master move by voitacek
immediately bringing in a piece that was
out of sorts rook d1
he takes d1 takes
takes c takes d4
queen e8 and notice how black
actually managed to reorganize his
pieces it all seemed so jumbled up
and didn't look at all too good
however now black has
a firm d5 control compensating for the
fact that this e6 pawn is somewhat
weakened
and as well as the a6 but it's much much
harder to get to
rookie one eyeing the target and that
weakness
rook b5
so it is actually duda's turn
to show how he is going to
make amends of this position because
black actually did a splendid job
reorganizing the queen is well placed
according the knight end upon the rook
is patrolling the fifth rank
and pressing this a5 square together
with the knight
so it is for duda right now
to try to activate his forces so let's
try to
think about that which one of white's
pieces
is kind of inactive and not being
part of the action at the moment
foreign
so at the moment the bishop is
doing a fine job defending the a pawn
the knight is right there controlling
possibly the most important squares in
this position
those center squares and the d4 square
the only piece for duda
that is sort of out of play right now
is this knight on g3 this knight on g3
isn't doing particularly a lot
you can't really go knight f5 because of
this brilliant defense of the
b5 rook so we've got to find a place
where it can prove to be useful
in comes knight to e4 by jankstov
he goes knight e4 hits the d6 bishop
and goes after the f6 knight
takes queen takes e4 and this is a great
trade
for duda because that knight is not in
the way anymore
and black actually has lost a defender
on the f6 square between d7
and objectively this position
is very much fine for black
black really does not have to fear the
future
even if white would take on e6 there's
plenty of play against
those weak a5 and e4 pawns
however here duda
the polish fighter comes up with a very
creative solution
which is very much vintage his style
and duda takes on h6
and bishop takes h6 is that typical move
that karpov
and the old guard of world champions
would never take why well
it constitutes a peace sacrifice is
there like a direct
refution to this move not really
is it bad
well it is somewhat dubious it's not
a hundred percent correct yet
from a practical standpoint duda does
get winning chances
that he'd otherwise wouldn't get and
this kind of
comes back to one quote i have from
anish erie
where he sort of compared his play with
magnus carlsen
and he said that magnus sort of gets
away
with with some more speculative
play that he that is anish giri is
willing to take
and this is something very similar to
that
duda is more than willing to
sort of step through that demarcation
line
saying i'm here to win this game if
it takes a little bit of gambling and
taking
chances i'm still going to go
that direction bishop h6 does exactly
that now black absolutely has to capture
queen g6 check so
black can move two directions black can
move to h8
or can move to f8
and there is a third one but it's sort
of a non-option
if you go queen g7 there's queen e8
check
and at the end of the day you lose that
knight on c6
and with the v king on h7 and upon
weakness on the e6 and a6
this is more or less lost for
the black player
so here voitacek is faced with a very
uncomfortable
choice you know your opponent
is bluffing but you're not certain how
and i often notice when people
watch these games live and openly
criticize the players well
you are watching that game
with no extra stress
and no invested interest of
trying to find the best move a best move
can actually give you a high standing
in the prog event and one simple mistake
can
throw it all away so there is this extra
stressors
worrying you and second of
all the only computer you can rely
is your own little head and brain
so you've got to be a five head playing
the position
you can't rely on anything else and it's
much more difficult
as it seems and you'll see in this game
so here voitacek plays
the logical quote-unquote move the king
h8 move
you want to move away from white's
pieces
but it turns out to be that king of
faith
the most illogical move you can think
about is the better one
and after queen takes h6 the
outstanding move of king e7 is something
that black should play is by all means
not something a human can do
openly running into the attack
and just saying well i do not see the
refutation
what is wrong with this this just must
be
completely fine for me and that is what
humans
can often not do because
it physically and visibly just seems
way too dangerous
so instead voitacek comes up with king
eight cheat which is more logical
but on the other hand less accurate
and these are those little mistakes that
makes
chess so interesting like it seems
that um it's all souls but a little
mistake
can change the rhythm of the game
so now white decides to take on h6 but
he
could have also gone for d5
of course you cannot take this pawn
because of rook e8
check you've got to give up the queen
otherwise it's mate
so rook takes d5 rook takes e6
threatening again rookie 8 and queen h6
so black has to go here rook e8
and after rook f5 black is holding but
interestingly enough
there is this extra option of rook d1
check
knight e1 takes ticks
and most of us would consider this
position
to be better for black
but this is one of the exceptions
actually it is wide who's better and it
has to do with the fact that this king
on h8
is way too exposed and
once white manages to take the asic
spawn
white will have an easier time attacking
the black king
than black to organize the light pieces
successfully those pieces are actually
not
coordinating well enough so kind of the
moral of the story with this one
if the light pieces don't coordinate
well enough
white is better otherwise
it is black who's better because the two
pieces are worth more
but in case it's two knights or they
just
don't cooperate well it is clearly the
advantage for the rook or rooks
now d5 wasn't played
duda played queen takes h6 instead queen
h7
and of course we get into a situation
where
duda isn't going to go for trades he
is way more interested in the attack
rightfully so
there's barely anything covering that
king apart from that lone queen
queen f6 queen g7
queen takes e6 and
just by a pure material count you can
tell
that actually white is
making big headways he has three pawns
for the piece
plus this king is ultra exposed on the
h8
square and it does not seem like it's
going to
survive the attack and indeed
cracks under pressure goes knight takes
d4
but after knight takes d4 queen takes d4
white has the finishing touches
and after those finishing moves
mike is just going to run out of
defensive ideas and going to get
checkmated
so here y to go screen h6 check
king here rookie e8 and here wurtashek
resigned because he saw after king f7
there's queen e6 check king g7
rook g8 check king h7 and queen g6
checkmate
and it's very interesting to note that
duda barely was any better in this game
maybe worse once he went for that
speculative but interesting bishop
sacrifice
but after that sacrifice he put
voit under so much pressure that he
cracked
and couldn't defend any longer he did
come up with one good defensive idea
but then he just crumbled
and played the decisive mistake knight
takes d4 so
this is the first game i wanted to show
from
ian kristof duda the second game i want
to show
was between duda and
the turtle steel champion jordan font
forest
let's take a look at that one
so this game is very interesting
because you're wondering how jordan from
forest
career is going to continue on he came
up with
this spectacular result of tying for
first
and taught to steal then moving on to
beat anish giri and claim the title
and here we see him sort of
lean back on his preparation from that
event and we're going to see
how duda reacts to that one c4
e5 knight f3
knight c6 bishop b5 ship a4
knight f6 castles knight takes e4
now this is sort of the modern
way of playing people
like to go into open variations
and then they add an extra little spicy
twist
and that's exactly what jordan from
forest
is going to do in this game however
compared to the previous time when
he was relatively unknown and they
didn't kind of expect anything
spectacular from him
now he is a target so whatever
interesting idea he springs the
opponents are prepared for them
d4 and
the main main variation has been
b5 bishop b3 d5
takes and bishop e6 this has been
popular
for a long while by now
and especially prominently faced and
played
in the match between karpov and korchnoy
lots of times and there was a legendary
game
played in 1995 between
gary kasparov and vichy anand
famously knight d2 knight c5
c3 d4 and knight g5 happened
which nowadays is considered
just a mainline move but at that moment
this was a bombshell-like novelty
and even if you just look at it it is
just spectacular as it seems
white gives a knight away seemingly for
nothing
but there are plenty of tactical tricks
looming and black does get into a bit of
trouble
if he does not know what is happening
and if you haven't checked it out yet
that is
the kasparov anon game which was won
in a spectacular fashion by gary casparo
but d4 bishop e7 is a variation
and has been played previously by
another dutch player jiron
piquette you might not know him
that much and that well if you're
a younger player but jeroen pickett was
the strongest
dutch player for a while in the 90s
and was considered a big prodigy of the
time
he worked with none other than victor
korchnoy
and he has essayed this idea of bishop
e7
rook e1 and b5
so even though jordan
improved on this line this has been
played
by jeroen piquet with some success
rook takes c4 and the punch line is that
black can go d5
double attacking the bishop and the rook
knight takes c5 knight takes c5
rook takes c5 of course you has to
have to take on e5 because if you don't
then your knight is hanging and
white is going to retain two
pieces versus the rook and compared to
that previous example
that i showed you to you guys here
white has more levee
for the pieces and white is just going
to be
much much better so now takes c5
rook takes c5 b takes a4
and just from a stylistic perspective
this does feel a lot like martial
variation
but with a different move order
and different tendencies
now this actually featured in the
tiebreaker between anish giri
and jordan fun photos but in that game
jordan
easily held a niche to a draw
but this time duda came prepared
goes queen e2 so
his first reaction is to make sure
that he can put pressure on that bishop
he's just not letting
jordan castle so easily that would
actually give up that bishop
bishop e6
and now sort of again
vintage duda he goes on
for the most aggressive moves
f4 again
saying you may not cancel here i'm going
to go f5
you move the bishop and i take yours on
e7
and you're just in big trouble so
duda is sort of questioning this whole
setup
by jordan and is
trying to keep his king in the center
g6 still the best defending that square
knight c3 attacking the a pawn
a3 and this is actually a funny moment
what has the choice of either capturing
the pawn
or just pushing the b-pawn once
and claiming that this a-pawn is going
to be more of a weakness than a strike
now regardless of which way or what way
you'd continue
here if you take on a3 oftentimes
those extra pawns would mean
little to nothing as these
pawns can't really advance too much and
they don't really cover important
squares either
so here duda goes b3 instead says in the
long run
that's going to be a weakness and i'd
rather keep
a healthy pawn structure anyways
bishop b4 knight takes d5
castles and this is very much
heavy preparation by both of the players
you can't really take on b4 because of
queen takes d4
check and black is
going to win some material
so instead duda centralizes
and that's actually the interesting part
of chess
even if you don't know theory if you
know the basic concepts you
barely can go wrong because most of your
pieces
will stand best in the center and look
at that
there is a big meeting going on
in the middle of four squares and it's
all white
as we can see bishop d6
however queen e4 seems a bit illogical
based on the fact that this rook is sort
of running out of space
but then again we come back to
the dilemma of what is worth
more does the rook worth more or a piece
and a pawn
and it turns out it's not as trivial
as you may think when we're just
starting out chess
actually you can
get enough compensation for the rook if
it's a piece and a pawn
so duda does go knight c3
and here black goes bishop f5 but if
bishop takes c5
white may go f takes e5 and because of
all those dark square weaknesses and a
weakened king's side
black is probably worse over here
so knight c3 bishop f5 still the best
move
still good stuff by both duda
and jordan but now we've got to decide
should we stay or should we go
they just got to let us know
should we stay or should we go
and of course duda always takes a
challenge so he takes on f5 and says
hey your bishop on d6 isn't quite that
good
it isn't really defending the king so
after this
trades the bishop isn't really a good
defensive piece
and it ain't really a good attacker
either because that pawn is well
protected
on the other hand white does have some
nasty threats of bringing the knight to
g5n to f6 later on
so white's threats are very real while
black's pieces are
somewhat scattered on the eighth
rookie eight knight e4 now that does not
mean that white
doesn't need to be precise might
absolutely need to be precise here
because black
can go and get counter chances if white
is not paying attention
frets on d4 same threats on the king
and on those pieces so knight e4
setting up the idea of knight f6 knight
g5 and black doesn't really have the
luxury of sacrificing the rogue back
why does up up upon in that case
bishop e7 bishop e3
bishop b7 is a great move by the way by
jordan he's trying to protect all those
squares
and with those entry squares blocked off
it seems that he is close
to get an even position
however that turns out not
to be the case actually
is not the case
so interestingly enough in this position
black has only one
one single way to
survive the position
and jordan either knew about it that it
exists
or he just did not know about like maybe
he didn't know about it
or he knew about it but forgot the move
and that's actually
part of the toughness
of current day chess you have a ver
you have to have a very good memory and
a good feel for the game
and i wouldn't even blame anyone not
finding this movie if they hadn't looked
at this
previously
and the outstanding move is bishop h4
which looks very illogical
but the point is not only does
he want to put pressure on the knight
and bishop with an eventual
queen e7 but also wants to take away the
g3 square from the knight
now here the best move is rook f1
the line continues with queen c8
knight f6 check takes
takes rook takes
check king here
f5 and
blank is up a whole rook
yet we'll have to be somewhat careful
not to mess up the position
rookie 2 f6
simple threat queen g7 you can even go
back and have d5
and the best move is to give up the rook
check walk the king to d7
and after takes rook takes c2
and believe it or not black has enough
play
because the rook and queen
is putting enough pressure and gives
enough counter play
for the lost pawns but these are those
very strange moves you've got to make
to be able to survive like these
are not easy moves to find if you don't
know
what to expect
f1 and if queen is 7
then there's rook f3 and if queen takes
c4 there's queen g
for check and black is
under some pressure as this king
on g eight that just moved to h8
is going to have to face
attacks on the dark squares
but he played queen c8 whether he didn't
know about
it he slipped and now
duda is going to be clinical
bishop h3 queen d3 keeping the pieces on
the board
he's saying the rook and bishop tandem
is gonna be stronger than your rooks
take sticks
queen e6 king f2 king f2 is again a
stylish move
he knows it's going to be an end game
very soon
and if possible i would love to have my
rook
go to h1 queen e4 rook d1
sure we are very ready to trade but
it has to be on our terms
a5 g4 c6
take stakes g5 again
making sure that there is no palm pushes
and if this bishop can ever show up
on f6 or e5 this king on
g8 is going to be completely paralyzed
which is critical in the end game phase
rook e8 rook d3
h6 takes the pawn
f5 all right so this is
another critical point white managed to
stabilize
there's no way jordan from forest will
be able to crash through
but of course young of duda wants
to win
so the question is how can white
try to attempt that
now we're kind of stuck with our pieces
if we move the bishop
we would let that rook in the second
rank
that wouldn't be ideal at all if we
would
try to go g4 that would simply fail to
have takes g4
and there's just too much pressure on
that bishop
so just by the process of elimination
you've got to go for c4 and create a
d-pass bond
6 d5 takes c takes d5
running the d-pawn down and that's also
not a bad
choice because notice that that square
is actually the same square as our
bishops
takes d6
rook d8 bishop c5
and here duda is putting up a master
class
that d6 pawn is well defended
and once this bishop gets a charger pawn
and with an a eventual a3 b4
it's going to be unvulnerable to any
attacks by the rooks king f7
rook d5 again centralizing
is the best thing you can do even in the
end games
king f6 bishop takes a3
rook h4 king f3
check rook takes a five and slowly but
surely duda is picking up
those pawns like berries there's
not much that black can do and there is
this eventual threat
of getting that bishop to e5 via bishop
b2
and then black will have no way
of winning the d6 pawn ever
rook f1 king e3
rookie eight so to
jordan's credit he is trying to create
some weaknesses in this position
rook takes f4 bishop c5
again trying to
charge that bishop over there once the
charger pawn
gets to b4 there is not much hope left
in that case for black rook g4
check king e6 check
king d7 rook takes f5 and now
black is straight out of pawns king
takes d6
a4 rook takes g2 and even though
um jordan managed to take
the kingside pawns these pawns are
menacing enough
they're connected passers and they're
also supported
by the rokan bishop so that is
also blake as you'll see rook g4
check rook h5 just
keeping that king out now if there would
be a check that king
would make a dash towards the queen side
it's rook g8 king c3 check of course
as with the side who has
just a rook and bishop you supposed to
keep that rook
just to keep variety for black obviously
one trade of the rooks would be more
beneficial
because there is another rook to
compensate for the lack of the other
one rook g6 okay chet
king d5 again piece activity
check duda does not want any part of
that
a5 rook h4 king b3 and now the king is
walking away through the back door
check king b7
bishop d4 e6
sacrifice and you really don't have any
ways to stop that
check king d5 ship f6
the a pawn is running you don't have any
rook g7 moves
a7 and here black resigned
king d5 is more of the computer move
showing
that it was a game over because
here jordan decided
to give up the fight so
i hope you very much enjoyed these games
by
young sister of duda and hope you
learned
how the polish fighter plays
his most aggressive chess thank you for
watching
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you